bienvenidos realicemos el problema 143
tenemos esta división que luce un poco
sospechosa bueno vamos a modificarla
ligeramente vamos a poner que esto es
igual a 3
x
1.001 esto es lo mismo si yo multiplico
3 por esto me va a dar esta cantidad
entre 2 x 1.001 que es lo mismo esto es
igual a esto pero la diferencia es que
ahora puedo quitar estos elementos que
son iguales y me va a quedar que el
resultado es 3
esto es igual a 1.5 que es mi opción
siguiente problema
problema número 144 y 4 - x / 2 x es
igual a x cuál será el valor de x
cuadrada más 3 x menos 4 vemos si lo
podemos simplificar vamos a multiplicar
ambos lados de esta ecuación por dos más
x nos va a quedar 4 x 4 - x es igual a x
por 2 más x va a ser 2 x más x al
cuadrado
sumemos x en ambos lados nos quedan 4
igual
x2 x va a ser 3x
+ x al cuadrado
y ahora vamos a restar 4 en ambos lados
de la ecuación nos va a quedar 0 es
igual a menos 4 + 3x
x cuadrada que es lo mismo
que tener el cris cuadrada + 3x menos 4
y vimos que esto es igual a 0 lo que nos
preguntan que justamente es esto cuál
será el valor de esto pues va a ser cero
que es nuestra opción ser
el siguiente problema número 145 esta
figura representa la sección transversal
del rotor de una nave y la distancia ave
de aquí acá la voy a marcar de una vez
la distancia de a ave
es de 13 metros cuál es el área de toda
esta sección transversal en metros
calculamos primero este triángulo de
aquí abajo que es un triángulo
rectángulo tengo la hipotenusa tengo uno
de los catetos y usamos el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar este otro
cateto que le voy a llamar x
x cuadrada x cuadrada + 5 al cuadrado es
25 + 25 va a ser igual a 13 al cuadrado
y 13 al cuadrado es 169 169 restamos 25
en ambos lados nos queda x cuadrada
igual a 169 menos 25 nos va a dar 144
144 y queremos el valor de x así que
vamos a sacar la raíz cuadrada en ambos
lados nos queda que x es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 144 que resulta ser 12 12
por 12 nos da 144 esto es 12 este lado
mide 12 metros
y ya que encontramos esta área nos
faltaría encontrar este pedacito de acá
que bueno este triángulo no se ve muy
fácil de manipular
pero algo que podemos hacer es completar
esto de manera que nos quede un
rectángulo
si yo completo este lado
y este lado de manera que me quede un
rectángulo y calculo el área del
rectángulo y le voy a restar si yo le
restó esta parte de aquí pues me va a
quedar el área que me interesa el área
del rotor que está aquí en este color
como rosa bueno vamos a hacer ya tengo
el valor de este lado entonces sé que el
valor de este lado también es 12 y sé
que aquí acaba de todo esto completo
esta distancia completa es de 5 y este
pedacito de acá es de 2 vamos a
encontrar el área de este triángulo
pequeño que también es un triángulo
rectángulo cuál es la diferencia si aquí
este pedacito 2
todo esto mide 5 cuál es la diferencia
cuánto medirá esta parte
5 - 23
esta parte de acá esta distancia
va a hacer de 3
por lo tanto para encontrar el área de
este triángulo les base por la altura
entre 23 x 12
entre dos esto es igual a 36
entre 2
es igual a 18
este es el área que mide esta parte de
acá este triangulito esta área la voy a
restar al área total del rectángulo que
es base por altura la base es 12 la
altura es 5 el área del rectángulo es 12
por 5 y eso es igual a 10 60 el área
total del rectángulo menos el área del
triángulo verde va a ser 60 menos 1860
menos 18 nos da 42 así que el área
transversal que nos preguntan es de 42
metros cuadrados de hecho el área no es
en metros es en metros cuadrados porque
es área aquí le ponemos este 12 que son
metros cuadrados y esta es mi opción c
opción c
muy bien siguiente problema número 146
x es mayor o igual que 0 o menor o igual
a 4 que es menor que 12 cuál de los
siguientes enunciados no puede ser el
valor de x porque vemos la opción de
menos 2 james nos dicen que es menor a
12 pero no nos dicen que sea mayor hacer
puede ser negativo 2 x menos 1 me da
este menos 2 así que esta opción no es
pero tenemos que x puede ser igual a 0
así que este valor tampoco es
6 bueno puede ser x2
igual a 3 y nos da este valor esta
opción no es podemos tener aquí que x e
igual a tres y que ye sea igual a 88 por
324 nos da este valor así que éste no es
y tenemos esta última opción que yo creo
que ésta es pero veamos es el valor 48
la única forma de obtener el 48 es
multiplicando 12 por 4 pero la aie no
alcanza el valor a 2 es menor que 2 en
lo menor igual así que esta opción no la
puedo obtener entonces esta es mi
respuesta en la opción y veamos el
siguiente problema tenemos esta figura y
nos dicen que este punto b representa un
punto de observación en un extremo de la
piscina que mira hacia un objeto del
fondo de la misma en la posición r
que aparenta estar en la posición s
la distancia vamos a marcar la de una
vez de el punto b a r esta distancia de
aquí acá es de 10 metros cuál será la
distancia en metros del lugar real del
objeto r y el lugar percibido s cuál
será esta distancia
pensemos al respecto
podemos encontrar esta distancia del
fondo esta distancia que no conozco y
que voy a llamar x que va de aquí a acá
ya que es la que podemos restar del
total y encontrar la distancia que nos
interesa drs
este es un triángulo rectángulo por lo
que podemos encontrar sus dimensiones
usando el teorema de pitágoras que es x
cuadrada más otro lado el cuadrado de
este lado 5 por 5 25 y esto es igual a
10 por 10 100
estamos 25 nuevos lados es igual a 75 x
va a ser igual a raíz de 75 raíz
cuadrada de 75 esta raíz va a estar
entre 8 y 9 8 por 8 64 que es menor a
esto y 9 por 9 81 que es mayor a esto
así que esta x que estoy buscando va a
ser mayor a 8 y menor a 92 pero veo que
las opciones están en términos de la
raíz cuadrada así que vamos a
simplificar esto lo podemos expresar
3 por 25 75 esto lo puede expresar como
3 por 25
3 por 25 y esto es igual a la raíz de 3
por la raíz de 25 que 55 por 5 25 5 por
raíz de 3 esta distancia x es igual a 5
por raíz cuadrada de 3
y si quiero conocer esta distancia de rs
debo restar esto a 10 10 metros menos 5
x raíz de 3 está en este término es la
opción
justamente entonces ya encontré mi
respuesta y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo